so some of you know I grew up in former
Yugoslavia and from 45 to about 90 it
was a Marxist state country and religion
was officially excluded from public life
to be locked up in the privacy of
believers hearts within the walls of
worshipping buildings with a goal of
making finally religion kind of man and
yet religion did play kind of
subterranean political alive an act of
worship even act of public confession
even me showing up with a cross around
my neck was a political act subversive
political act and often these houses of
worship swore places where resistance to
the regime was being completed silently
and then after nineteen ninety kind of
religion burst into the public scene and
play the role and played well not such a
glorious role in ethnic conflicts in the
former Yugoslavia and I think there may
be relationship between the suppression
of religion in the one hand and it's
inglorious role in fomenting conflicts
religionist was suppressed and partly it
was suppressed for ideological reasons
it was a Marxist regime but partly it
was depressed because during the World
War two there was significant element of
religion in the fighting between various
ethnic ethnic groups and so terrassa
teas were committed either in the name
of religion or if not in the name of
religion at least with a blessing of
religion so so it was suppressed and
suppression contributed to to this to
this conflict and religion was partly
suppressed because or originals partly
violent but in the 90s because it was
suppressed and suddenly people wanted to
lead their lives as they saw fit and
they wanted to kind of resist these
encroachments of state and also of
others upon their religious lives but I
think primarily it was violent because
it functioned as a marker
of contested ethnic identity and less as
a genuine way of of life it was way to
demarcate groups and given oral sanctity
to the group belonging rather than a way
of embracing away way of life you could
be an atheist and Orthodox at the same
time no problem with that at all and so
two lessons were forced upon me as I was
growing up and that is or two issues and
two challenges how to diminish the role
of religion implementing conflict and
how to make it a practice of religion as
an agent of reconciliation and then how
to create space for religious agents to
express and bring to bear faith on all
spheres of life these two issues were
fundamental in in former Yugoslavia I
think they're also fundamental and have
been fundamental throughout the course
that we have we have we have had and
faiths role as peacemakers and faiths
contribution in making globalization
serve human flourishing and the common
good those were kind of to access around
which we organized the course and as it
turns out of course these two don't
often sit very easily next two together
right the more people bring their
religious convictions to bear in public
issues in a pluralistic setting well
there's some likelihood that they're
going to go come into conflicts with one
another and that's the challenge that we
are facing I think to their how to have
religions who are in on the one hand
religious people free and acted on the
other hand how to diminish conflicts
that partly result from that in a
shrunken world so and I think there are
two sets of issues that we have to
attend when we think about these these
issues and those are the sets of issues
that concern the character of
globalization and the other is set of
issues is that concern the character
fades themselves what does it mean to
have multiple fades in one common world
so so diverse fades and their role in
the context of globalization
so there I think in terms of things that
we've covered in the course they're kind
of two sets of conditions for fades to
function well in the context of
globalization so that fades and
globalization processes don't go onto a
collision course and one set of
conditions is concerns political
institutions and governments and there
is you will recall i talked about faith
friendly political institutions and
governments fades often turn violet in
the context of at least democratic
sensibilities when there when they
perceive that governments themselves are
not fade friendly when folks don't have
freedom of religion to exercise religion
especially not in the public realm when
there's no openness to considering
religious perspectives on overarching
issues of global core of common concern
and when governments aren't in part or
when governments are being partial when
they're clearly favoring one group
rather than the the other but there's
also the other that's the political
condition but there's something also
like like an economic condition and I
think we need to think also in terms of
faith friendly economic institutions and
agents now what I mean by faith friendly
economic institutions I don't mean so
much faith friendly in terms of ability
of people afraid to express their faith
within the space of the workplace
although that may be part of religious
freedom as well but I mean by that open
being open to values that stem from
faith traditions that might shape
economic her life instead of insisting
that the economic life observes the
logic of its own and it's impervious to
the values that come from the outside so
if a friendly means one open to being
shaped by values with regard to the
internal functioning of the market or of
businesses and Max Faber is a good
example in a world via services and
Francis Fukuyama social capital
importance of the trust and so forth but
faith friendly also means open by being
shape
x values with regard to the purposes of
markets and or the market and of
businesses now of course that means also
other world views of course I don't have
to repeat that every time right now just
face but other worldviews that bring
values to the market or businesses but
purposes of our lives are their kind of
central to the question of a fade and I
was reminded of this as I was flipping
through a book by John Polkinghorne
scientist priest physicist priest and
who distinguishes way of Sciences
approach things in way religion approach
these kind of questions that they asked
and so you ask the question why is a
kettle boiling right well one way to
answer it if you give water more and
more thermal energy at a certain
temperature you know the speed of
molecules will increase and the forces
holding them together will give way to
the forces that are pushing them pushing
them apart and they will turn from
liquid state to a gas state something of
that sort would go an explanation some
of you will know how to put that in a
better way than I do and the other way
to ask that question is because Tony
asked for a cup of tea right that's why
the kettle is boiling right and that
suggests the purpose of the activity
rather than causal explanation of what's
happening in terms of the boiling
process itself and I think religions
they ask these purpose kind of question
consistently and it's essential to to
them to pose that question the purposes
of our individual lives institutional
lives in deed of the whole of the setup
we call globalization processes and so
the question has to be well what this
thing for again as I put it before to be
open critically I think it's essential
for economic institutions and actors to
be open to reflect critically on how the
market in particular business contribute
to human floor
now we can talk about individual actors
and I was just recently at an event
which title of which was for CEOs and
the title of which was broadening the
definition of success right to think in
terms of success in broader terms than
just the profit bottom bottom line you
can think in terms of individual actors
its consumers again bring your values to
what they do maybe it's more difficult
to bring to think about purposes with
regards to individual businesses and
corporations although there too I mean
stuff that I read and that will tell me
whether it makes any sense or not
whether they will go anywhere or not but
there's a lot of talk right about
something like triple bottom line people
planet and profit right now people of
faith and faith traditions can do
something with that less if the only
concern is profit right and the same is
true also with the market as a whole
national economies some folks talk about
economy as a people in Planet mattered
mattered or they're these these attempts
to really find how we measure gross
national a gross domestic product is
this a kind of strange way of measuring
success but there's this weird thing go
gross happiness product or someone that
the people are people are trying to read
speech by a king of bhutan about about
this this question but you know on the
on the other hand you know i don't know
who's I think Kennedy said something
like like this nothing that truly
matters is measured by gross domestic
product and there may be controversial
but at any rate alternative is this if
globalization if its political economic
aspects as well as its technological
cultural or other aspects if it's close
to being shaped by visions of human
flourishing and values associated with
it then it will be on a collision course
with religious traditions Eve on the
other hand globalization is open to be
shaped by visions of human flourishing I
think there may be a tension Laden
relationship but nonetheless will be
relationship that will be a beneficial
one now that's in terms of relationship
between phase
traditions together and the
globalization processes but of course
that immediately raises the questions of
the relationship between faith
traditions themselves because visions of
human flourishing differ across faiths
even they differ within a particular
faith so we need dialogue between
religions and to engage in fruitful
interfaith dialogue but about fades
themselves as well as about their
relationship to globalization I think we
need at least a few things one of them
is we need knowledge simple we need
knowledge about other faiths about each
other information about other religions
plain simple data but I think we also
need kind of deeper kind of knowledge
and that what I'm going to say now may
sound a little bit touchy-feely maybe
not but somebody has said that the
encounter between two persons they're
always for I think that in the counter
between persons they're always six first
you and me then it's your image of me in
my image of you and then there's my
image of myself and your image of
yourself and these things don't quite
always overlap and part and parcel of
the dialogues I think between religious
traditions is not some simply objective
information about those religious
traditions but it's also perceptions of
oneself in relationship to the other
adjustment of my vision of you with your
vision of yourself and also vice versa
so there's kind of a deeper knowledge
that is born out of an encounter second
thing is we need to find ways of
affirming the truth of a given way of
life religiously define way of life and
embracing tolerance both of these
together now there are religious people
there are also secularists who believe
that the affirmation of the truth of
one's moral stance is incompatible with
tolerance if so faiths will always
inevitably clash and the in under the
conditions of global is
process there is nothing nothing else to
unless fades end up being profoundly
redefined so that the formation of truth
in their claims is not part and parcel
of what they what they are about but it
is possible to affirm the truth of one's
own religion and yet be tolerant or more
precisely engines because of that be
tolerant and we have done some study in
the common word document which not only
affirms on the basis of affirmation of
truth of both Islam and Christianity not
only tolerance but indeed benevolence
indeed beneficence toward others now
essential conditions for something like
that is and there's where fates might
need to undergo at least certain aspects
of fades might need to undergo
transformation essential condition is
realization that our views about the
absolute are not absolute themselves
that we have only limited knowledge or
as the Apostle Paul says we always see
through the glass darkly never
completely right that's a sin of
provision ality of all religious
knowledge is part and parcel of the
religious consciousness itself not
always of the consciousness of really
old religious actors right but it is
part and parcel of what many religions
claim in their original original sources
so realization that our views about the
absolute are not themselves absolute a
sense also that we can learn from the
other that other is not there simply to
stand next to us but that he or she is
potential source of benefit again rich
our own perspectives on how we live and
I think most fundamentally shift of
emphasis from what is different among
faiths to what is common it's amazing
about what happens if you just shift the
interest from one to the other ring
because you can make a case for one or
the other depending of what is your
primary concern so we have knowledge of
one another affirmation of truth of the
way of life combined with tolerance and
third is common acts of faith I think
relations
between faiths are not primarily
exchange of ideas not primarily also
engagement in one neither it will be in
each other's rituals it's a matter of
living in side by side in the common
world common space local space but also
increasingly common global world we
share common spaces and because we share
common spaces we also face common
problems you know that maybe education
of children deterioration of
neighborhoods abject poverty poverty
around the world ecological planets all
sorts of issues that we either a local
or global level actually share as
commonly perceived problems and we can
strive then also to devise common or at
least partly overlapping solutions and
so relations between faiths do not start
with knowledge as my list suggested i
started with knowledge they actually
start with action together this was
brought to my attention very vividly
when I recently visited Rick Warren I
spoke at his public at least his civic
forum we had dinner together and he was
we were talking about this I'm
interfaith issues and he's quite
interested in interfaith issues and it
looks me in the face and said miroslav I
know your academic and you're interested
in idea but ideas are really not the
place to start this thing he says the
the the way you start this thing and the
movement goes from the hand to the heart
to the head right t3h s a typical
iteration of a successful preacher
preacher right hand heart and head edit
of course stayed with me just because of
because of that and he has profound
wisdom right it's because we act
together a force track together in a
common word world that we can develop
empathy with one another and from that
empathy can develop a deeper
understanding as well as interest in
overlapping consensus between us living
together as multiple fades in the common
world
thank you